c'est yves pour l'amener à 10 tac tac
tac c'est que ces dazhou la duke et jo
burg et thonon données
arrêté
tenir un cap 5 7 voix sur la tête de ma
mère
on dirait toujours les témoins tous ces
anonymes sont rigoni au pve miellat et
fatou patou qui a toute la musique que
j'aime bien de la
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est omar aux marques et aux maris site
us alors que l'on me faire de procès pas
de perruque barbante a donné pour
l'instant je me suis franchement vous
êtes les trois aussi nul j'arrive à m'en
sortir
c'est mal comme alcon qui brûle comme on
donne l'envié l'envié d'avoir envie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
toc toc toc jean-michel anouar al bounni
alors ces noix iny
[Applaudissements]
serra qu'elle a ra quelque chose en nous
de tennessee
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il ne peut pas vous garder sous la main
tu prends ta mort c'est yves y va pour
le mieux
c'est vouloir pour tous ceux donnés me
sent très seul
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
que là
temps
à
[Musique]